well good evening and welcome to this
meeting of employment committee the
first item on the agenda is attendances
have we had any apologies
i have not received any apologies
thank you uh
minutes of the last meeting is everybody
content that they're an accurate record
yeah i'm happy with that i'll move it
thank you
uh i'm not aware that we've received any
questions from the public can you
confirm that's correct alex
uh yes i can confirm that no questions
have been received from the public
and
i've not been notified that there's any
urgent business that we need to be
dealing with
is that correct alex
uh yes sir no matter divergent business
i've arisen
thank you the next item on the agenda is
the people's update september 2021 is
that you angela
it is councillor bennett um so
i was going to go through the the people
update
um so i will take the report has read
and as highlighted in the earlier
meeting
um rather than go through it in in any
great detail that's okay with you
counselor bennett
that's fine i just have one question
angela could you expand on the new
agency social worker framework it
doesn't go into any detail but that's
something that we always keep a close
eye on in this committee
yeah so as as you'll appreciate you know
over the um the last few years we have
been struggling to recruit to agency
social workers in particular
and so the team have worked really
closely with the service um to
commission a agency social work
framework and it's
new um it's only been up and running
probably for a month or so and so what
i'll do counselor bennett is i'll bring
forward some information to the next
meeting in december by which time there
will be um opportunities to um
understand the numbers the volumes of
information going through that
particular framework it's really an
extension of the current arrangements
that we've got in place because as as
i've had we've had the conversations
previously and i think we've we've
always struggled to
attract
um excellent in social workers and
experienced social workers and it's not
just a trafford problem it's a regional
a local problem it's a great manchester
problem
it's a national problem but we're doing
all that we can to um as i say to ensure
that we do attract and
bring in
um
suitably experienced and qualified
social workers in this in this period
that we we absolutely need them
and i think in the wider update um we
talk about the work that we're doing in
the children's service we designed
so there's a lot of work on going um in
that part in that service redesign and
to reshape um and
that will help hopefully stem the demand
for agency work but we're not quite
there yet we're just in the process
of finalizing phase one and recruiting
to the newly designed role roles and
populating the new structure
so um there will be a sort of a leading
time i guess until we're we're kind of
successful with with that
thank you
does anybody have any questions for
angela on this item
yeah cancer laptop
it's just really about the domestic
abuse charter and the council is
obviously committed to to sign up does
that mean that we haven't yet signed up
to it
you want me to come in on that one
angela
sorry kate i'm struggling to get off me
yes please do you want to come in and
just update counselor acting on on the
work that we're doing in this space yeah
so we have liaise with gmb and we
haven't agreed to the date sign up to
the charter however we are working on
the different strands required um you
know to sign up to the charter um so
yeah we we haven't done yet but your
plans are in in place we're linking in
with um
uh
one of our providers around domestic
abuse to put on some training for our
mental health first aiders and for
managers so we'll have a campaign of
awareness raising when i think which
will tie into the launch we'll be
promoting our e-learning module for all
staffs to increase general colleague
awareness so yeah we have we haven't
launched yet but plans are in place and
that's part of that's been linked to
capacity and other priorities
yeah okay
the chip chair the other issues that i
just wanted very briefly to touch on was
the birthday leave scheme
for one year
uh and the additional two flexi days
given to that to our knowledge the um
you know the precious stuff have been
under through this pandemic which i'm
really you know really happy about
um
but it it
it's three
sort of
flexi days in a way isn't it you know
um because
if if you had you know a number of staff
and had a birthday on the same day or
whatever you know i i don't know
if you're able to work through that
do you think it's
a management of the scheme david rather
than happiness
obviously i'm pleased that with that
knowledge uh the work that staff have
done
over the years
over the last couple years
i suspect i suspect staff will
appreciate this
this offer and i'm sure they'll work
with managers that it's not going to
cause a problem in the individual
services but i'm sure there must be a
plan in place uh perhaps angela could
explain that to us
yeah thanks thanks councillor bennett i
guess um you know the decision um was
taken in light of the um excessive
number of hours that we know our staff
had worked and so our flex time scheme
is is you know um
it's it's an old scheme it's it's
inherent in a lot of local authorities
and so we we looked at initially sort of
stepping outside of that scheme what we
didn't want to do was to um you know to
run the risk of being out of line with
our local authority counterparts we're
already experiencing recruitment um
issues in certain parts of the business
so
what we've done is we took a decision
that in order to reward those those
people who've actually worked
well over um the two days extra and we
have the information to evidence that
um what we're doing is we're using the
opportunity to reward the extra leave
but we're also using the opportunity to
reset the dial as well
and it's back to um where we are with
our health and well-being promotion as
well so we're resetting the dial back to
zero after the first of april um
obviously we're not going to be so
prescriptive if people for whatever
reason can't take their
extra leave we'll work in some
flexibilities around that but it's more
also around
individuals and managers and being
careful not to accrue
those extra hours and because of the way
that we've had to work over the last 18
months you know the pandemic
created a situation it was all hands on
deck you know it was and everybody did
just go the extra mile and just
continued
the work and i think also the adjustment
in
leaving the office and working at home
you know we had the extra sort of
commute time
and instead of
using that time to sort of you know get
some um work-life balance and get that
distance i think people just continue to
work
so again
it's it's it was a decision it's it was
for a year we've taken the decision to
award the additional leave in
recognition of the amount of hours that
we know our staff have worked over that
period of time but again we're resetting
the dial back to zero and there's a
conscious piece of work with managers to
ensure that
they don't
staff don't work additional hours unless
it's absolutely essential to the
business
so it's all about kind of getting the
priorities back um in in in order as
well and ensuring that as i say our
staff are just working those
additional hours if they need to
yeah
okay
any further questions for angela on this
item
can't see anybody else yeah right then
we'll move on to the workplace
reintegration update
which is quite important
okay so i'll just um introduce the paper
and then kate's going to to talk us
through it so again you know we've we
talked to you at the last meeting the
the jcp meeting and we also talked about
the the approach to smart working at the
last employment committee as well
um and and again it's about how we want
our workforce to be able to work even
more flexibly
uh using the emerging technology that
we've we've been talking about so i
thought it was useful just to keep it on
the agenda and just to continue to
update you on on the latest position
because it is quite a
fast-moving um piece of work
um i mean kate's going to take you
through where we are now and and the
feedback that we've got from the recent
engagement sessions that we held
throughout july and august and
some of the things that we started to
put in place to support staff to still
feel safe when they return
um
and i think i've said this earlier for
some staff
it's the first time that they've
actually visited the office as well um
for example
so again our reintegration proposals are
emerging and that's at such a pace
um and i'm going to hand over without
further ado to kate to take us through
the what her and nina and the team have
been working on over the last
three months since we talked about it
last time
okay thanks angela um so so as angela's
just detailed i won't go back over and
explain sort of the smart working
proposal because we shared that at the
last meeting in june and we also gave an
overview of that in the report um
so basically you know the work we've
undertaken in june and july has been a
sort of a massive focus of attention
around engaging colleagues we've linked
him with lots of different stakeholders
our trade union colleagues met with them
went through the sort of comprehensive
presentation about our plans our
different work streams our enablers
and they were really comfortable with
our sort of direction of travel
we liaised with our directorate
management team meetings as well to
start start to think about which work
style would lend themselves to the staff
in their different services and see if
they had any sort of concerns that we
need to consider for different sort of
chunks of the workforce
and then say i think the biggest piece
of work really and most important in a
lot of ways is the engagement with
colleagues across the council so we
we sort of designed
dedicated sessions and we ran those via
the teams mechanism
and in the sessions we shared a
presentation on our proposals
so that colleagues could fully
understand our plans
um
after that we then
got colleagues to break into smaller
breakout groups um where they've whizzed
off to a little private meeting with
some other colleagues
and they discussed several questions
that we proposed and they gave feedback
on those questions
so you know across the seven sessions i
think we had about 240 staff engage
initially we'd only put five on but we
had high demands we we responded to that
demand and put some more sessions on
because we want to to get as many people
sort of physically slash virtually in
those sessions as we could
um
so
we also wanted to reach people who might
not be able to get on a session so we
wanted a very similar experience for
them so what we did was we developed a
dedicated intranet page
where staff could go on they could view
the first session because we had
recorded it
they could download the presentation
that we shared and reflect on that and
take the time to go through that they
could contact us if they wanted to pose
any questions we created an online form
so that they could give feedback on
exactly the same questions that were
used in the team sessions
if they wanted to we suggested they can
meet with their individual teams within
their team so they could have those
discussions and then complete the
feedback form
um so you know we got quite a bit of
feedback and we collated and analyzed
all of that feedback during august to
see if there's anything we needed to do
differently or to sort of understand
where we might need to focus more of our
attention
um
so the one of the questions we had a
slider pull um as a precursor to the
team sessions and we decided to revisit
a question that we asked last year
around staff who um use the pc for some
of their work
would they be open to um working at home
some of the time in future either want
to do that or do they want to move back
to being in the office every day
and the result we've got was completely
reflective of the result that we had
last year when we posed that question
um acknowledging the fact that the
sample size was much smaller however it
was a sample and the results that have
correlated so it was like a little
temperature check really um and
throughout the sessions the feedback
from people attending was that they were
supportive of um working from home some
of the time
um
the approach we've got has got the
flexibility within anyway so that
different staff in different teams might
split their week differently some might
spend a lot of time at home because of
the nature of their business and also
potentially for personal circumstances
some might
spend much more time in the office for
various reasons and we also have one
work style which is uh predominantly
office based as well which might work
from home occasions so there's lots of
flexibility for staff for different
circumstances and for teams who are
undertaking different business with
different business models
so on the whole from the results you
know the feedback was pretty positive um
and there wasn't anything that sort of
came out that we hadn't really sort of
thought about in advance um
some of it it was interesting that
obviously it did um it did align with
some of our thinking and some of our i
suppose concerns are things that we're
really conscious that we need to get
right um to make this work
um
so in terms of some of the specific
questions we asked i'll just give you
some highlights um in terms of what
staff said they liked about the
proposals they said they liked the
flexibility because they'd seen that
through the pandemic working from home
they
said that yet we need that supportive
technology to get this right they said
they really liked not having to commute
every day so that'll still be a
continuing benefit and they could see
that there was you know increases in
productivity they'd seen that from
working from home during the pandemic
in terms of the concerns and challenges
which actually is really more important
for us
to get this right
there wasn't one strong theme that came
out so there wasn't a high volume of
responses around particular areas
there's a real spread across lots of
different themes
i thought that was really interesting
and that was quite reassuring as well
that there wasn't something screaming
out that people thought was going to be
a big problem
um
so all the feedback is being fed into
the all the the project team members if
you like just so they can factor into
their work streams to make sure we're
providing what we need to to get this
right
and acknowledging the different um
positions people are in any different
concerns
so in terms of what further support is
required
the key themes that came through were
equipment
so equipment we're talking probably
about monitors chairs desks etc making
sure you've got your laptop riser you
know separate keyboard et cetera um it
support was key um because obviously
there have been some
issues through the pandemic with people
working from home so that's you know
position has massively improved and will
continue to improve with m365
um and they also needed um more you know
the appropriate guidance for managers
and staff around how the new ways of
working will work for them
um
so what else to tell you
um
so i think based on all the engagement
that we've undertaken and all the
feedback that we've pulled together
um you know we believe that this is the
right thing to do for traffic council at
the moment um you know it is something
that will evolve over time
um
you know there'll be some areas that at
different points in time will need to
have more focus on and we might need to
refine things you know we'll be learning
as we're going along
so we're up to the moment in terms of
reintegration and smart working in terms
of reintegration from september we're
encouraging staff to start to come back
into offices where they're not in
working in offices at the moment
so we're suggesting they come in one or
two days a week um
and we want managers to ensure that
managers are having conversations with
staff before they come back into the
office to see how they feel about it
they've got anxieties concerns if so how
can we support them to work through
those and put mechanisms in place and
angela mentioned all the well-being
resources that we've massively improved
recently so there's lots of things that
people can you know pick up when they
need
um when people come back in we you know
there will be a safe environment we've
kept a lot of the measures that we've
had through the pandemic in place
because we think it's sensible it's the
right thing to do as you know
transmission levels are still changing
the school's going back obviously last
week today we don't know the impact of
that yet
um so yeah so it's really a cautious
approach but starting
with an eye to the future and how we
will work
and as more people start to come into
our offices it will give them a chance
to test some of our equipment so test
the
hybrid meeting um
mechanism
hybrid meeting set up if you like some
of our communal spaces where people can
come together and collaborate it's been
quite difficult piloting that when we
haven't had enough people in the
building to actually go and use those so
it's really important that we do all of
that we don't want to start investing in
in
furniture and expensive pieces of i.t
equipment before we know that what we
need for the future so we do need that
sort of testing phase that piloting
phase
um
obviously there are lots of projects
ongoing such as microsoft 365 which are
gradually being implemented over the
course of a few months so some of the
benefits of that we won't realize for a
while so that's why i'm saying it's sort
of an evolving work in progress
um
but the aim at the moment is to sort of
have it fully implemented and embedded
our new ways of working in march um and
you know as we go along towards that we
will be sort of learning from feedback
to refine that
and what we will do is we can bring
further reports i think angela mentioned
earlier we can bring further reports
along to update employment committee so
they know where things are up to they
know how we're doing basically
okay and i'll stop there um any
questions anyone
can't see it
i don't have a question chad i'm just
wondering um because i obviously spoke
to this item at jcp whether we could
just repeat
the purposes of the minutes and
the remarks that i had to make so that
they're just as relevant to this meeting
as they were to the last is what i'm
trying to say that sort of thing
absolutely thank you councillor williams
and i think you make some very very
valid points and i hope that will
surface on the next agenda
uh counselor boys did you have a
question well this is a brief one yeah
it's quick on the surveys coming back in
just i mean how many if any how many
responses
actually were around the
wish for
people to return
to the office
full time
based on the fact that they lived alone
either they had no partner or of
whatever reason
that basically they
they
were desperately missing
being in work with colleagues because
they had very little social interaction
outside of work was that a significant
thing or
just like in any way yeah do you want me
to respond on that angel or
please kate yes go ahead
so so that wasn't something we that's
very very specific we didn't
specifically ask a question and gather
information on that however that is
built into our you know to our suggested
approach so what we said with the four
work styles is we do have an office
based work style so if a member of staff
has a reason
for the exactly what you said counselor
that they maybe have isolation and work
is part of their social being if you
like and they want to be physically with
people four or five days a week that's
something we'll very much accommodate
say we've got suitable flexibility
because we understand people's
circumstances are very different and
that would be you know that if that's
really impacting them then you know we'd
be stupid not to you know we need to
take on board how people are feeling um
so yeah that's we don't have specific
information about how many people in
that position but that's something we
can definitely offer and our managers
would have those conversations with
staff if that's how they're feeling
thanks kate
thanks very much for that because it was
um i i'd have come across one one one
member of staff who was absolutely in
that situation in terms of
the last 18 months had been purgatory
for the individual uh
a home worker so thanks very much
i think i think something's you know
similar but not a bit different is also
we're conscious that some people don't
have a suitable environment at home you
might we will have colleagues who might
be in a you know shared house where they
don't have an ideal workspace so again
if they've got reasons why really
working at home for any substantial
amount of time is not going to work
again we'll take that on board and work
with them to see you know what's best
for them
thanks kate any further questions for
kate on this item
can't see any other hands raised
thanks kate then we'll move on to agency
spend is that you angela
it is councillor bennett i'm going to
cover this this item
okay so the agency spend report covers
the period april to june 2021 it's
quarter one
um i'll take the report as read i'm sure
you've already and i'll just highlight
some of the key information um so
starting with children's services they
have seen a decrease in spend
as compared to quarter four and for the
same period last year which is great
news
um we've already highlighted some of the
work that's underway in the people
update um in this directorate so
um i'll just kind of um counter through
some of some of that so
we introduced a market supplement in
april 2021
um
and this will help hopefully support
some of the immediate recruitment and
retention of our frontline social
workers
and get us into a bit more of a
competitive place with our gm neighbours
we're continuing to work alongside the
um serge redesign project team
and we're providing ongoing support to
the senior leadership team with a number
of organizational development
interventions for example we've
delivered two sessions to date
and this includes some reflective space
and development with with their senior
leadership team looking at key change
models as they also continue their
transition journey and this is helping
to facilitate meaningful challenge
meaningful dialogue
on the behaviors that they want to see
role modeled in in their
service
so we've continued our offer um with
managing change so we're supporting them
with um the psychology of change for
example
um and we've been running interview
skills with those colleagues who are
looking to progress their careers within
the service and as i mentioned earlier
we're just on implementation of phase
one and starting to populate the new
structure and there are some internal
recruitment processes going on there
so i think you know where the hr service
is continuing to to support the
children's services redesign um process
um from a recruitment perspective um
we've engaged a recruitment consultancy
to work in partnership with them
and to develop a um attractive high
quality social worker recruitment
campaign
and this is hopefully going to go live
um within the next week or so it's going
to run for a period of three months
initially um and there is some
flexibility to extend the campaign if if
we need to
um and this will hopefully again help to
reduce the the reliance on agency
workers once it's it's um got to that
end stage
we're doing a lot of work within our
learning and development space to
support staff with their professional
development and that's about helping
them to retain in in the service
and we're giving them much needed
additional support
to our newly qualified social workers
who are undergoing the
assessed and supported year in
employment the asye
as well as mentoring practice educators
of social work students on placements
again the intention there is to is to
keep the students ideally one once they
qualify and and on board them to roles
with trafford so they have a great
experience with us whilst they're here
we've got several grow your own routes
into social work we've got the social
worker apprenticeship program
and we've currently got two social
worker apprentices in children's
services who are due to qualify
in october this year and we've got three
more who are in their second year of
this program
and it's about to launch the opportunity
again with a start date for three
apprentices in september
we're part of the greater manchester
step up partnership which is a 15-month
post-graduate fast-track route into
social work we employed our first
graduate in march and we're due to take
on three more step up students in
january 2022
for several years we've supported um
frontline two frontline units and this
is a 12 month postgraduate route into
children's social work
um and and another eight students will
qualify
for this route in september this year
so we're doing an awful lot of work in
that children's
social work and in the children's
service redesign space as well and the
service is also doing a lot of work to
mitigate um the risks of losing really
great staff but also encouraging
newly qualified social workers to to
come in and work for trafford and the
more experienced ones as well
okay so with adults then the adult spend
has increased from course one
and in comparison with the same time
last year predominantly again in the
area of social workers and support
workers
so you may know we were struggling
nationally with resourcing some of the
support worker roles and especially with
the
um the requirement now for mandatory
vaccinations in care homes that's also
going to have an impact in that part of
the world
so but we're just on boarding nine newly
qualified social workers in adults and
that's going to provide some much needed
capacity
um and it's gonna we're gonna continue
to support them and as they start their
careers um from within our learning and
development specialist roles
and then we've got the trafford academy
um which
is is starting to um go into schools to
talk to them about having encouraging a
career in in health and care and that
that work will continue but it will take
time obviously to yield with the results
okay so in governance and community
strategy and the spend on agency workers
has decreased
um is compared with quarters of four
um and increased if compared with the
same time last year and there's nine
active assignments
so bev and the hr ops team are working
closely with service to redesign
um so that the roles are more
commercially attractive um
we've commissioned a b to support the
recruitment of a new director of legal
and governance and who's going to be our
new monitoring officer for when the
current um postholder uh the corporate
director retires next april and the
advert for that will be live later this
week
in finance and systems um they have no
agency staff at all this period um which
is great news and there are five active
assignments in strategy and resources
one of which will fall off because we've
just taken
one of them onto a fixed term contract
so that should reduce next period
and in the place directorate they've had
to put some temporary arrangements in
place to support some key roles and
pending recruitment to to some of those
key roles so their agency spend has
increased slightly
this time
so in summary um
agency and consultancy spend has
decreased this quarter from quarter four
but it's slightly higher than the same
period last year
and i guess given the challenges we
faced and responding to the pandemic and
this isn't totally unexpected um
and i'll just finish off by saying you
know um services continue to monitor all
spend
and the resourcing team continues to
support them
to recruit the right person with the
right skills at some pace
and in some cases it you know they do
need to have a
a temporary agency resource to support
them over the you know the bumps in the
road so um i'll pause there
thanks angela councillor boys you got
question for angela
sorry that's a legacy hand chairman i'm
sorry
just
apologize for that sorry just hang on
right okay i got it right
does anybody else have any questions or
queries about this report
i can't see anybody else i think um we
should applaud all the proactive efforts
you're making in terms of social work
it's quite refreshing to see that we are
actually trying to attract people in and
once we've got them do everything we can
to retain them so thank you for that
report angela
uh next item on the agenda is the
quarterly report on exemptions to the
sickness policy this is a verbal update
is that you andrew
no i'm going to ask bev um to come in
and do the verbal update uh councillor
bennett
thank you
thank you very much good afternoon
um
so the update for this quarter on the
occupational sick pay exceptions
we've seen a reduction from last quarter
and which is helpful to note so last
time from memory we had 10 this time
we've had eight separate requests but
that relates to
six people
all of those requests were approved
um there the requests have been received
from two main directorates so within the
children's area there were six requests
and in strategy resources there were two
requests
and the ones that were received in the
children's area related to four people
um last time we discussed around uh the
requests fifty percent of them had been
related to long covered or covered
itself
um and i'm happy to report there's been
a significant reduction in that now and
only one of the six requests related to
long covered and it is the same
individual so it's not new individuals
it's the same individual unfortunately
that's experiencing the long-covered
symptoms
we've had um two exception requests
relating to mental health conditions two
relating to cancer conditions and one is
another um conditions
in addition to that i'm happy to report
that four of those six people those
individuals those employees have now
either returned to work or have um left
the organization so been supported in
that way
which is which is good news for them as
individuals and certainly great news
where they've been able to return to the
service
so that's the report from last quarter
and just to bring you up to date with
where we're at now because obviously the
last quarter ended in june 2021 and
given that we're at the 6th of september
just to give you a flavor really of what
we've received between june and now
we've currently received four requests
in that period of time
um
yeah so that's it two of which have been
approved and two are awaiting approval
at the moment
so there is a reduction in the number
that we're seeing
and we're hoping for this next quarter
but we are continuing to support people
wherever we possibly can uh facing
significant financial challenges as a
result of um continuing ill health
thank you any questions
many thanks beverly does anybody want to
have any questions on this item
you know can't see anybody no thank you
beverly
thank you
well that brings us to the end of the
agenda unless anybody's got any other
business any queries
any comments
you know well thank you for your
attendance and uh
have a pleasant evening
bye
thank you chair thank you colleagues
thank you
hi take